>> WHEN I HAVE A RIDE, Y'ALL,
TEMPERATURES DROPPING.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS?
>> IT'S THAT TIME OF YEAR WE
FIND A MAN TO KEEP US WARM
THROUGH THESE COLD MONTHS.
>> BUT NOT JUST ANY MAN WILL DO.
WE OUT HERE LOOKING FOR SOME --
>> BIG BOYS.
♪ IT'S A DECISION, IT'S A REASON
TO GET A BIG BOY, I NEED A BIG
BOY.
GIVE ME A BIG BOY ♪
♪ IT'S ALL THE GIRLS ARE LEAVING
TO GET A BIG BOY ♪
♪ I NEED A BIG BOY WITH POLAR
BEAR ARMS, KEEPS ME SNOW IN THE
WINTER SNOWSTORM ♪
♪ HE BRING IN MY GROCERIES IN
JUST ONE TRIP ♪
♪ WHEN THE SUN COMES BACK, I
NEED A BIG BOY HOTTY, MAKES HIS
OWN HEAT WITH A BIG BOY BODY ♪
♪ BIG BOY WITH A BIG OLD BACK, A
CALIFORNIA KING, REFRIGERATOR
STACKED ♪
♪ BUTTER BACON, CHEESE, AND
LASAGNA IN THE TRAY ♪
♪ AND I HOPE HE ASKS ME TO BE
HIS WINTER WIFE BECAUSE MESSING
WITH A BIG BOY WILL CHANGE YOUR
LIFE ♪
♪ IT'S CUPPING SEASON, IT'S ALL
THE GIRLS NEED A BIG BOY, I WANT
A BIG BOY, GIMME A BIG BOY ♪
♪ I NEED A BIG BOY BODY LIKE A
BOUNCER, BIG MOUTH BREATHER AND
LEGS LIKE A MONSTER ♪
♪ GET IN THE BED AND HE GOING TO
DO ME RIGHT, GET IN THE BED AND
HE SNORE ALL NIGHT ♪
♪ AND THEN HE STOPS ♪
BABE?
DID THIS MAN JUST DIE?
♪ ANYTHING I NEED, MY BIG BOY
GOT IT ♪
♪ IF I NEED A SNACK, HE GOT
SNICKERS IN HIS POCKET ♪
♪ BIG BOYHOODDY, YOU KNOW I'M
GOING TO ROCK IT ♪
♪ AND IF WE TRAVEL, YOU KNOW WE
GOING IN FIRST CLASS BECAUSE HE
DON'T FIT IN THE BACK ♪
♪ HEY, BIG BOYS, GO BIG BOYS, I
LIKE THE BIG BOYS ♪
♪ WHAT ABOUT GIRLS?
>> I LIKE GIRLS, BUT THEY CAN'T
KEEP ME WARM.
♪ ALL I DO IS WORK AND STRESS
AND I COULD USE A BIG BOY SO I
COULD JUST RELAX ♪
♪ HE CAN HAVE THEM LOVE HANDLES
IN THE FRONT AND IN THE BACK ♪
♪ IF WE TALKING GIRLS, I LIKE MY
GIRLS BIG ♪
♪ IT'S CUPPING SEASON, IT'S NOW
WE GOT A REASON TO GET A BIG
BOY, I WANT A BIG BOY, GIMME A
BIG BOY.
>> WE OUT HERE LADIES.
WE THE REASON FOR THE SEASON.
THESE BEARS DON'T HIBERNATE IN
THE WINTER.
YOU KNOW WHERE TO FIND US.
WE'LL BE SHOVELING SNOW IN
SHORTS.
♪ BIG-BA-BIG BOYS ♪